Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Outlast 2.
We're on our way to see Papa Knoth.
But I think we're gonna be moving through some heretic territory because it can't just be this house.
Maybe it is. Hellooooo?
Who's there?
Chris Traeger?
From Outlast 1?
Okay, no nevermind. Goodbye. I was a mistooken. Alright, so we gotta get down there.
Oh, it seems about a good path as any. Why not? Why not do that?
Why Knoth do that?
Oh? Really through, through...
Through your incredible deductive reasoning you've deduced that there is an elevator right here. Can I do this?
Yeah, they must they seem so technologically advanced. *Distant male scream*
That's always a good way to start off an episode.
Just screaming from the distance of a pained death. Oh, hi. I don't like that.
Uh-huh
Mark: Uh-oh, Uh-oh, oh, Uh-oh, ooh, ah ah.
Can you just, can you open it?
*Door creaking open* Hello?
Okay, you keep rambling about whatever you're rambling about now.
And I'm going to carry on with what I'm doing, which is very important work such that I get my wife back.
There's nothing here, but potatoes.
Aghh. I don't need potatoes. I need a way out.
Ohh great of course. I'll probably be coming back that way a long time from now
For now... Where are you?
Where are you?
You know what? I'm just going to go for it.
*Distant muttering*
Okay, so I don't know where to go, but there's got to be a generator around here somewhere.
If they're not going to show me that I'm just gonna have to find it on my own.
Why is there dead people everywhere?!
There can't be this many people to kill!
There just can't be, right? There's a dead body right there! Go through?
Okay, ohhh.
Good
Why?
Why so much dead?!
Why so many dead bodies every- oh that's CREEPY! *Zoom for emphasis
That's fucking CREEPY! *SUPER ZOOM for emphasis!
Okay, fine then.
Let's go.
Hello, found you. Is this an easter egg or something? Oh boy.
Mark (Knoth voice): "Now as I behold the living creature, God's lamentation
"fresh in my mind.
"I asked 'Are you the Four strange creatures revealed to Ezekiel?',
"and the voice came from the firmament that has over their heads said unto me, Son of Man.
"And sayeth the Lord you shall be Ezekiel to these wretched times and
"Muhammad to its chosen people and Noah to the flood of blood inflamed
"that will destroy the heathens and gentiles and Pharisees.
"And like the four creatures of Ezekiel and of John and of Isaiah and of
"Daniel, behold a wheel there upon the Earth by the living creatures!"
"Thousands of eyes and none of them human but black and
"intelligent and shining like the eyes of beasts ready for slaughter and where the unfazed
"creatures looked, the eyes of the rings focused
"for the spirit of the creatures was in the wheels, and the spirit of the wheels
Was in the creature."
(Normal voice): Ok, getting better. Not, not bad, not bad getting closer to it.
I need to hear Papa Knoth a bit more before I become fully indoctrinated.
Yeah, this was definitely fun.
Good to know that. I'm finding all the secret easter egg pieces of his
Uh
literary proficiency.
Oh, hi.
I don't wanna do that!
Oh my god.
Okay. Is she just gonna be standing there?
You keep looking at me. Why are you looking at me?
Okay
Oh boy. Oh boy. This is so weird
I'd rather not revel in that ecstasy
Oh, she's just repeating herself over and over
Just standing there in the middle of the road
(Shouting): Bam, bitch! I'm here now!
Fuck all y'all!
(DEFENSES AT MAXIMUM)
(Normal): Okay. All right, then
I don't think this bedroom of children really deserve this but seems like all their children are dead
So this cult's gonna die out soon enough, I guess.
Okay so...
This must be the place
It seems to be the end of the line- oh no. There's more okay. I just got to follow the line
And then see what I gotta do.
Okay, all right. You keep rambling there. You keep having a fun time.
Imma- Oooh, hi! Heretic you say oh, hi, Heretic you say!? That's not me! Oh boy.
Oh, this ain't good. I oh God no! Oh
I-Yayu
I don't know where I'm going oh, it's a dead end.
Yeahehehe Ow! Fucking ow!
Mark: Fucking asshole
Male: Consume the flesh and spice it well!
Mark: I don't wanna do that
Ow fucking goddamn it slam the goddamn door on them
Where do I go, where I go ah fuck slam the doooooor! Fuck you. Okay... I gotta go gotta go.
Oh, I don't know where I'm going. I can't see shit. I can't see shit!
Uh oh. Well that ain't good
Okay, alright seems like they may have stupidly lost me like a bunch of idiots even though
I was a bit of an idiot to be of caught by them. To be have caught by them, but they led me right here.
The fools!
Simeon, I need to talk to you and deepest secret cause if you're knowing the
unctures and such and medicines
I hope you know I do not trade any more words than's strictly needful when we make the trip in the damned world for gasoline and
electricals and other such
necessaries as we can't make
I've got something friendly with the publican boy who sells us the pills Papa needs and when I mentioned them and study aids the boy
laughed and said a body didn't need penicillin for studying unless a body with studying "gash."
Have you heard of such things I do not want to ask Papa for fear of I don't know what?
but I do not want to accidentally poison him neither, please come see me
Ah
Ok so it's a slightly
Not so intelligent person going into town
So they did have to integrate with the real world, "the real world," to get supplies for gasoline
Somehow
Well it didn't seem to....
There we go. What If I had just gone without firing it up all night.
*Spooked noises* Hi fucking hi! Hi, okay. Thank you!
Mark (normal): I just fixed your generator for you, ma'am
How happy are you?
Ohh. You're reveling in the ecstasy of the lord I see, ah, good! My favorite choice of revelry.
Man your animations are a bit stiff, and that's what makes you slightly more disconcerting than if you
Weren't that. okay? All right, then.
Okay, you keep doing that.
Ohh. Boy, they locked me in here. good!
Rmm Blood
rmm PAIN! Alright, I'm gonna go this way. Oh, I just went in a big goddamn circle. Oh, that's what I did
All right, then I'm gonna go dow- Ow fuck. I'm gonna go down this way.
I'm not going to hide in there. That's for damn sure.
*Distant male screaming*
What was that?
I heard someone screaming, but now no one is screaming no more.
Is they dead? Were you not dead?
Okay...
Well, lock, they got smart they listened to Papa Knoth and they lock their damn doors
Well, I'm just going to make my way back because I'm. Nooo
Female: This way is forgiven.
Mark: I don't want to be forgiven. I don't want to be forgiven. I don't wanna be forgiven I don't want to be forgiven
I don't want to be forgiven. I don't wanna be forgiven. I don't want to be forgiven.
I don't want to be forgiven. I don't want to be forgiven. Oh no no no. I'm gonna hide the barrel
*Chorus intensifies*
Can the chorus stop screaming please, just for a little bit?
I don't wanna die.
I don't even know if she was chasing me in the first place, but it seemed like it
Where's she at?
Okay, She is
Where is she?
Oh.
Kind of got it right there. That's where she is. Okay. So maybe I can go in this way.
Nope
"I am hath sent me unto you?" Learn grammar lady!
Oh boy. You better not be down here
There's nothing down here anyway.
This is a place to get lost and then die.
Okay you're down there
Mark: Ooo wayayayay! Ah! Oh, oh!
Female: *Aggressive Screaming*
Mark: You didn't see nothin, you didn't see nothin
Owie, owie. who, who, who, owww
Okay, I'm in trouble. I'm in trouble. Come on. Just fucking.
What are you doing?
(squealing) What were you doing!? What were you stuck on!?
That didn't make any oh fucking come on. What was I stuck on?
I was stuck on nothing. I was stuck on a whole lot of nothing. I was stuck on dick and dirt
Ugh
Fuck
Oh boy
Alright, Imma rush through this because I've been taking
The long way around, huh?
(music intensifies) Ah fucking why! Why'd you do that, you were fine!
You were peaceful, you were a lovely person. The fuck!
Uh
I don't know what the fuck is happening here
She's up there, and I'm trying to get by... Okay. Here's my chance. I'm just gonna go for it.
*SPOOKIPLIER INTENSIFIES*
*Female Screaming*
Uh-oh, uh-oh. I am booking it. I am
fucking flying. Okay. Go go go
Yes, go go go. Hey hey hey hey hey
Okay, you're gonna be ravenous in your penance. Are you get a penance yourself!?
or are you gonna penance someone like me? I don't know if I deserve all this penance.
I don't know if I deserve it at all
Alrighty then
Yeesh
Yeeshy, yooshy. Okay
Where am I now what does this say
"Temple Gate established 1971
"Founded by Sullivan Knoth of the Modern Ezekiel. Their knives sharp for the enemy it felt inevitable like a dream or a memory
But not mine."
Okay, then
Alrighty
Founded in '71 that means Knoth is a bit old now
He's getting up in years!
*Distant singing*
Mark: (screaming) Whoa, whoa, whoa. Oh okay, I shouldn't have looked in that well. Oh boy!!!
I shouldn't have looked in that well!
I shouldn't have looked in that well. Oh, I vaguely remember this now. I don't recall the well being like that!
Yeesh...
Please, what? Please what?
I didn't let nothing happen. What have I let happen?
*Loud crashing*
Oooooookay.
Okay good. I'm back here.
Oh, I know we're not alone here. I'm not even alone inside my own mind
Cause everything is getting all kinds of messed up.
Jessica: He's coming.
Mark: Oh boy.
Oh, I know how this one goes
Hi, okay, all right. Let's just... let's just get this over with
Hi, cos I think we all know where.. ah oh okay. Oh there's that Award winning smile.
(Chica?)
*Male Laughing*
Principal, is that you?
All right here we go again...
Mark: Oh boy! Oh, wait. Oh music box. Oh hello hey Lynn. I'm bored, Mr.
Cohen's still talking about, shut up bitch
Oh, nice centaur
Oh boy
Yeah uhh, it's weird. How we're in Jessica's locker, and it's Jessica's, huh?
There's gonna be a jack-in-the-box? Better not be a jack-in-the-box.
Why am I doing this?
Why did I do that?
That's like a "Horror Movie 101" you never crank the music box that there.
(Cos grammar)
Because that leads to death
Oh boy, oh boy
Yeah, that was a bad idea to do that.
Mark: Heyyyy
Mark: Ohhhh
*Girl Screaming*
Mark: Oh ok oh, I'm gonna go here first
What's in here? I don't care stop screaming
I think I got shit to do a lot of shit to do I've been making a lot of errors
And I need these bandages. I need it badly
All right, oh hello
What are you?
Ohhh
Eugh...
Mark: So I was kind of right. Oh, maybe not I remember you.
Blake: Fuck.
Mark: Hello!
Kay, goodbye! Alrighty then... Can I get out?
Well this don't seem good. Oh
Hey, hi!
Hello, OW!
AGAIN!
Ok alright then. Thank you
I'm gonna run now. I vaguely remember this.
[False bam] I was gonna bam that real good. I was gonna bam it so good like you never knew you could. Alright here we go.
Run run run- Ooh hello... Alright. Why so many dead?!
How are they gonna have any congregations if they keep killing!
Oh, no, oh, no, I got a lock that. I gotta lock it. Yeah- EUGH
No, don't open any lock it!
LOCK IT!
Okay I locked it, they'll never be able to get in now. Now they have no way.
There is no way. Oh God what do I do about this?
How am I supposed to be able to... Like, that one's jammed.
There's no window that I can climb through is there? Oh this one! No, down here! Ok got it just in time, too
He didn't see a thing!
(Proud Markimoo)
Whatever, keep talking to the darkness. I'm down here winning! (Charlie Sheen)
Alright...
I don't know where this is gonna go but hopefully it's gonna get me outta here
Oh, hi!
Okay, all right, then I'm assuming you can't do anything to me so I'm just gonna sked- Oh whoa whoa. Whoa, hi. OH GOD!!!
Oh, what the fuck?
He was coming in after me. I didn't realize it. I couldn't see it, he was a cloak black figure!
Ok, here we go again. I guess.
Uh, not bam little moderate bamage
Alright, but now at least I know where to go. I'm just going to go. I'm not even gonna waste any time.
Not gonna waste ANY time. I'm just gonna go for it. It's gonna be awesome
And I'm gonna gun it fast as I can
Round down here. And if I just go for it maybe he can't get to me in time and I'll be alive and not dead
Don't do it. No no no no
No, no, no, no, you don't! Ohhhh!
Ahhh?
Okay, alright. I was just supposed to gun it. Who'da thunk'd? Who'da thunk'd? Who'da thunk that was what I was supposed to do? I didn't thunk that
Jeezums
Those frickin assholes, what is that??? Oh it's a well.
Oh, is that the same well that I just fell in to and for some reason that is actually logical and actually happened
I don't know what's in here, but I'm going in here!
Lock that. Oh, it's got no lock on it. Oh boy. Oh boy is there a bed or something?
Oh! Ooh!
Mark: I don't want to do that.
WOE to the bloody city!
Oh, hi okay yeah, um this seems unsafe.
This seems bad. They're- they're kind of everywhere
Okay so if I can go- whoa, okay, don't go through that one. Oh boy can I hide under a bed? NO! *Spooked noises
No, no, no, no, no, no. You don't know that you don't know that. You don't know anything about consuming the flesh!
He has no idea!
He has no idea. I am too smart for his kind around here.
Ho Hell yeah, (quickly changes mind) oh hell no! Hell no hell no. Ooh Hell no! Hell yeah!
Can you- Can you frickin'!
Lock, okay. I think we're good. Hide in the closet.
Hide in the closet good, Ol' "Amnesia" style. Hide in the closet. Don't worry about a thing.
They will go away and I will be just fine.
That is how this usually goes and I am not going to betray myself by going outside of this goddamn box.
If you even think for a second that I'm gonna go out there and face whatever Monstrosities are fighting me?
No!
No, no, no, no, no, I am not and I will not and I will never do that
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. (Sassy Mark)
*SPOOKED!* What the fuck? Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my God... OH MY GOD!
Ohhh fuuuck me!
Holy shitballs, oh my God. I'm gonna die. Oh, he saw that. Oh you definitely saw that.   uh
Jeezum, this guy will not leave me alone!
Okay, I'm assuming that was him running the other way which is good... I think?
Go go go. Go go go. Come on. Come on. What are you doing? What do you- you got to be kidding me, this way?
No, no, no, no come on. Just MMM. Just MMMMMMM
Come on. Okay. Go go go go go go. Okay? Okay? Okay? Okay? We're good. We're good
We're good this looks dark and scary and spooky. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Ok ok, we're fine
Who're you?
Who are you? Why are you here?
I'm just gonna sit here and record you for a while because this is normal human behavior.
And uhh mmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm
Okay! and I'm done ok cool
You just carry on
Carry on
Poor thing...
Ok, I don't know why they got her down here
but I'm assuming that some part of the process of getting rid of the antichrist is uh
Purging
Not a good way. I don't know what the fuck. Oh, God. Oh, oh
oh
Oh, I'm not gonna zoom in on that. Oh
Well here, we got one quick one. *SPEEDY ZOOM
God all right then no zooms, no zoomz
*SUPER SPEEDY ZOOMZ* Okay...
Fuck
It's like a non-stop horror show everywhere you look... Just bad after bad, after bad.
"God knows what I've done and he forces my eyes on it when I'm weak, and when I'm scared it was not my fault
"fault that Judah could not swim nor the lust he felt for me. I would have saved him had I the strength. I do not doubt you
"God, please spare me the suffering such force dreams even when I do not sleep
"I cannot keep watching him drown.
Accept my death as penances
"I am newly heavy with Papa Knoth's child and wracked with pains such as I have never known
"Surely the infant in my womb must be the archfiend for the affliction of nightmares and agonies that fill and surround me.
I am yours."
Okay, could Papa Knoth stop...
Just straight up raping everybody in the town? That is, that's like the first thing that I would like in
the New World Order here and then just everybody just kind of stop. Juuus kinda stahp
Just cos you know you just *ewww*
Eugh...
Eugh.
All of it's just eugh...
Alright well, carrying on.
Whatever else this hellhole holds in store for us
Hello. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy.
*Not trusting this bullshit*
"HE'S IN THE HOUSE!"
NO I'M NOT!
*SLAMS DOOR*
What the Hell!?
Oh fuck you guys! Oh, fuck you guys. Oh fuck you guys
Fuck you assholes. No goddamn it!
What is this shit??? This fucking Garbo?
*Mocking* "He's upstairs!" Thanks, Douche.
Oh boy, okay. Where am I going? I'm jumping over. I'm jumping over! Ow, my ankle bones!
Okay, where am I going where am I going? I don't even know anymore...
I see him! Can that guy shut the fuck up for one second???
Oh, HEEYAH!
(Sorta worked?)
That was supposed to be a sick slide, but it didn't work that way...
Goddamn it these guys are persistent!
I mean I guess that makes sense the whole town is looking for me and I guess they wouldn't give up that easily.
It's kind of a non-stop
Adrenaline Rush
Oh boy...
Okay, you missed me, bitch aha!
Dickhole!!!
Alright, so I just got to get through here and then I gotta keep running. I think it's a corn field nearby maybe?
Maybe, maybe? I can lose them in the corn field.
Ohhhhh gonna "yump" for it! Oh boy. Hell yeah. I'm gonna open for it.
Oh, oh, okay, all right! Let's do this I guess. Weee, okay that was a good idea. No, no don't go up! WHAT ARE YOU DOING?!
Oh boy, okay, all right keep going then
Fuck!
All right, they're gonna- Man! They're just tearing it up. Fuck dude! Give it up, not worth it!
How do I get in here? Good!
Just hide under the bed, hide under the bed, hide under the bed, hide under the bed! Okay...
Fuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuck
I think that's a good place to in this video that was
insanity and yet we made it through somehow with a few scars on us, but we made it through nonetheless, so thank you everybody
so much for watching. Let me know how I'm doing the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video
Bye, bye
*Funky techno rave music.*
Mark made it through, relatively unharmed, thankfully.
Let's hope he doesn't get hurt as much in the next video.
See you then, everyone!
Editors OUT!